Speaker 1: . Let's try.
Let's go elsewhere.
Let's go to oh, you know who we should go
to.
We we have to figure out what's going on.
Let's go to new Wrangler from California.
Nug, you're on the air.
New wrangler, you were on the air if you want
to join me.
Speaker 5: Oh, yes, hello, David.
For some reason, didn't you?
Speaker 1: Sounds like user error, I don't
know.
Speaker 5: Yes, it must be too many nerves
or something.
Speaker 1: What can I do for you?
Speaker 5: Well, before I ask my question,
I wanted to clarify that, according to a post
on your celebrity, had callers use speakerphone.
Would you prefer I use speakerphone?
Speaker 1: No, no, thank you.
Speaker 5: OK, OK, good.
All if that post is wrong and it claims that
ad callers prefaced their question with the
long monologue.
Let me begin with mine.
So it all started when, OK, I'm not going
to I'm not going to do that.
All right.
Question written down.
And it's coming now, please.
OK, so the people that are unhappy with the
employer employee structure of capitalism,
I would rather be in a worker cooperative
that just isn't there yet.
What message can we offer as progressives
other than maybe like Copan?
Wait.
Speaker 1: Well, I guess it's not Copan.
Wait, it's start a worker cooperative, right?
I mean, it seems that the quickest way to
be part of a worker cooperative rather than
waiting around is to to get involved in one
and start one.
I don't know what advice I would have.
Speaker 5: Sorry for the question.
I also was going to say other than start a
co-op, because it takes a lot of money.
Speaker 1: So you're saying, man, if people
want more work or co-ops other than waiting
for it to become more prevalent, coping with
the fact that it's not and other than starting
one themselves, what can they do?
Speaker 5: And maybe I can formulate that
question.
Speaker 1: Well, no, no, it's fine.
I mean, maybe call your elected officials
and encourage them to, I don't know, pass
maybe preferential tax treatment for worker
co-ops.
Maybe there's something there that could maybe,
you know, look at if you want to operate at
the city or town level, look at maybe grants
for worker co-ops on rent subsidies or something
like, I don't know any, you know, anything
that would make it more appealing, I guess,
for a company to be structured that way.
Speaker 5: Actually, calling an elected rep
sounds like a good idea.
Yeah.
OK, well, thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, there it is, new wrangler
with a very specific question, which we love,
which we love.
Let's go next to Brittany.
But there's just so many people that are wanting
to get on.
Let's go to Ofay from California.
Avea on air.
Speaker 5: So I have a trial with their children
after he was guilty, I hopped on all right
wing telegram and it was a lot of people were
getting pissed off.
I thought it was a guilty verdict.
Yeah.
And it wasn't just like thousands of people.
So what would be the best approach to try
to explain to the people, like in real life
about why he was found guilty?
Speaker 1: See, the thing that's tough about
this is any time you're not, you know, part
of the trial, I mean, some people watched
all of it, OK, but very often people just
react and say it was the wrong result because
it's not the result that I wanted because
of what it means politically or culturally
rather than this was an adjudication by the
jurors in the room of the facts in the case
and applying those facts to what the law is.
There have been lots of trials where the verdicts
have been things I didn't want.
But you have to respect the verdict because
you're not one of the jurors in this case.
I believe that the verdict does actually do
something in terms of hopefully signaling
to police that that there will be accountability.
So, you know, to me, it's less about convincing
anyone that the verdict was right or wrong,
but more about the fact that if this is the
way we adjudicate these things, then it was
fairly decided by a jury and we have no choice
but to stand by that.
I'm not that keen on arguing about the merits
of the case.
And a lot of my commentary in the aftermath,
looking at right wing media going completely
bonkers, is that they sort of seem to be abandoning
their own principles about how we decide guilt
or innocence, because in this case, they wanted
not guilty, whereas it's like, do you respect
that this is the system we have or don't you?
Speaker 5: It seems like they want criminal
justice for them, but not for anyone else.
Speaker 1: It's like with many of these things,
it's like with medical issues, it's like with
debt and deficit.
It's the they claim that they have certain
values.
But then as soon as those values and infrastructure
lead to an outcome they don't want, they throw
away the fact that they claim to respect the
system we have.
It's pathetic.
Speaker 5: Is it a question of culture?
Yeah.
What are your thoughts on modern monetary
theory?
Speaker 1: Oh, I have I have close to ten
clips about it.
I've done a bunch of interviews with some
of the top MMT people.
I mean, generally speaking, my view is a dollar
of debt is not created equal.
And what matters is what are we deficit spending
in order to fund?
Is it economically stimulative or isn't it?
And that's the way we should be thinking about
the national debt.
Speaker 5: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Avi from California.
Great to hear from you.
Speaker 1: Let's go next to Haley from Georgia.
Haley, you are on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
This is the first time I've called a great
welcome.
So my question kind of starts off with, you
know, I'm from Georgia.
I live in Augusta.
It's the second most populous city in Georgia.
And we are kind of split by two different
counties, one very blue, one very red.
We work extremely hard to remove corrupt officials
in the 20 20 election based on the majority
vote of our entire state, like electing senators
and electing Joe Biden.
Sure.
And still, it was extremely close.
We almost didn't give our electoral votes
to Biden.
We almost didn't elect.
We're not going district by district.
There are many Republicans that are running
unopposed in the General Assembly, and it's
impossible to change our state laws and our
congressional representation on a lot of our
our population is tired from all this all
these elections.
What more do you think that we can do in twenty,
twenty two to ensure that we don't lose one?
OK, and also to change our state representation?
Speaker 1: Well, the it's very important for
people to understand that politics is much
more than just getting involved in presidential
or Senate or even US congressional seats.
And as you point out, a lot of what is being
done when you look at education, when you
look at abortion, when you look at broadband,
I mean, all of these issues are hugely determined
by the state legislatures and state senates.
And so I think what we have to do is constantly
remind people that particularly in places
like Georgia, with unopposed Republicans,
they have to start being opposed.
You have to start mounting campaigns from
the left and there's no shortage of opportunities
to get involved.
It's really I think it's just really a reminder,
Haley, a lot of people just think about their
vote for Senate.
They vote for president, and then that's basically
it.
And you have to start earlier and you have
to start building candidates that can actually
challenge some of these Republicans.
Now, some of them may just win because a lot
of the way that the the state is sliced up
is good for Republicans.
And so we have to we have to understand that
that we're up against that as well.
But if they're unopposed, then you don't even
have a shot.
Right?
Speaker 2: I know.
It's so unfortunate.
Yeah.
Thank you for answering my question.
I just wanted to get that out there to everybody
to.
Speaker 1: Yes.
And get involved in state Senate state legislature
like Haley is saying.
Yes.
All right, Haley, thank you.
OK, Haley's gone, thank you very much, Haley,
very important, and that applies to just about
every state, I would say every state, really.